musique est gratuite
encore faut
merci du fond du coeur
il
merci beaucoup
le prix
tout y est c'est toi maintenant et toi
tincu merci merci du fond du coeur
vraiment merci isabelle
je vous remercie je ne sais pas si je
pleure parce que je réalise l'âge que
j'ai maintenant
mais non vraiment merci du fond du coeur
ce soir il est difficile de penser à
vous de parler d'autre chose que ce qui
se passe en ukraine
mais comme antoine l'a dit en début de
cérémonie nous sommes ici deux courts
célébrer le cinéma ainsi je souhaite
adresser tous mes remerciements à
l'académie c'est merci pour l'honneur
incroyable qui m'est réservé merci à
véronique caïla eric toledano grégory
collier merci maxime saada également
vraiment c'est un privilège véritable
privilège d'être parmi vous ce soir et
c'est un privilège de recevoir ce césar
d'honneur des mains de mon amie de ma
collègue issa l'homme à l'homme dont je
vénère la carrière je ne sais pas
si beaux biceps vous représenter le
cinéma français vraiment ça me touche
beaucoup et que vous soyez présente ici
c'est parfait on vous fait c'est le
summum merci hier à je parle français
comme une vache espagnole
en
anglais le gravement savez j'ai toujours
admiré la capacité du cinéma français
êtres aimés mais aussi d'être célébrée à
l'échelle nationale par son propre
public ce n'est pas toujours le cas dans
d'autres pays y compris dans mon pays
natal l'australie et je suis aussi formé
par l' influence profonde que le cinéma
face et a pu avoir avec ils continuent
d'avoir d'ailleurs sur notre perception
des possibilités qui s'offrent à nous en
terme de forme en terme de narration
j'ai jamais je n'oublierai la claque que
j'ai pris en regardant alors que je
n'avais que 15 ans le film un condamné à
mort s'est échappée de bresson c'est un
film auquel j'ai beaucoup pensé ces
derniers jours étant donné les courses y
a t il vérifie et je pense que personne
dans cette salle n'a besoin d'être
persuadé du pouvoir du septième art de
faire avancer les choses de susciter la
conversation et de la faire avancer
parce que je pense que l'avenir avant
toute chose il est imaginée dans
l'esprit des arts 10 et j'ai eu
énormément de chance dans ma carrière et
je pense que je fais du cinéma depuis
suffisamment longtemps pour pouvoir
qualifier mon boss de carrière j'ai eu
la sorgue la chance disait 'je de
travailler au côté de l'ex-roi du cinéma
qui m'ont beaucoup aidé des réalisateurs
des scénaristes des acteurs et actrices
bien sûr mais aussi des cinématographe
des monteurs des costumiers d'aider des
jeunes des spécialistes du décor des
compositeurs des musiciens des coiffeurs
des maquilleurs qui vraiment nous offre
une perspective nouvelle qui nous invite
à établir des liens entre des événements
ou les images aléatoire église ce
faisant les offres une manière tout à
fait nouvelle de comprendre le monde qui
nous entoure une manière humaine de
comprendre ce monde qui nous entoure et
je crois que c'est la marque de fabrique
de la créativité et participer à ces
dialogues à ces conversations tenté de
création ces dernières années ça a été
un privilège une source d'inspiration
pour voir mais je vais être honnête
c'est aussi ce qui m'a permis de rester
saine d'esprit ou en tout cas
relativement saine d'esprit dans cette
période incroyable et très étrange une
nouvelle soit merci du fond du coeur de
cet honneur qui est très particulier je
suis très touchée félicitations à tous
les nommer ce soir et félicitations
d'ailleurs elle une belle et ce qui
aurait dû être nommé c'est beaucoup
[Applaudissements]